ペリッ（パイの実を箱を開ける）
こういう時いやな気持ちになるよね
こんにちははじめしゃちょーです…
という挨拶がもう嫌になりました
（ハムっ）
いろーんなYoutuberがいますね
いろーんなYoutuberが居るんですけれども
こうなんかね皆さんやっぱ特徴的なんすよ
こうなんか…挨拶！いろんな挨拶
挨拶ね、やっぱね…
いろんな挨拶する人いるじゃないですか
こういろんな挨拶
いろんな挨拶するんですけど、僕…
そのなんか特徴的なことがないくて
自慢じゃないんですけど
僕のモノマネしてる人が
ほぼいません（ドヤ）
それはなぜかというと
僕に特徴がないから。
sssそれはそれでかっこいいな。
特徴がほしい。うヴうヴうヴうヴ（泣く）
やってたんすよ、こう動画の最後に
じゃあな！って…
秋田！！！
あああああああああああ
もうやだやだやだやだ
もうやだ！
じゃあな！っとかそういうの
もうなんか普通すぎてそんなのもう
全然もうだめだよ、ポイッですよ、ポイッ
もっとこう…今年やっぱね
もっとこうなんかキャッチーなのがほしいんです
キャッチーなやつ
皆さんお気づきだと思いますけど
じゃあな結構言ってませんからね
最近
もう飽きちゃったんですよ、じゃあな
普通すぎて
去年はもうエンディング変えて
今のエンディングで満足しているんですけども
なんか特徴的なもっとこう僕の…なんか…こう…
うまく説明できねーや！！
なんて言えばいいんだろう
あの…わかります？
IDENTITYというかさ
個性 ！個性がほしいわけよもっと
もうちょっと個性がほしいんで…
k…（口にパイの実投げる）k…oh…
もし仮にいま僕にあるとしたらたぶん
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです。
と
じゃあな。
うぇえええええええええええええええい
ダサい！
ダサいよ！
そんなの！
ありそうだよ！
うわああああああああああああもう
あの自分で言ったら恥ずかしいですよ
もし仮にですよ
もし仮に…今考えますよ
なんかないかなあ
（爆発音）
まじでやめとこう
こうキャッチーなものをつくる能力には欠けていると
自負しております。
だから僕、こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです、と
じゃあな、しか思い浮かばなかったんですけども
あの…
挨拶決めましょう
僕やりたいんですよこういうの…
こういうのなんかやりたいんですけど
ないんですよ
なのでちょっと今回は皆様に
僕の挨拶を募集しようと思います。
なにとぞ、なにとぞ、よろしくお願い致します、
コメントだけでもいいんですけどなんか
手振りとかね、こう色々あるじゃないですか
こういう（ダメ、絶対）
あ、違う
なんかこう色んな手振りとかの説明を加えて
喋る内容をよかったらコメント欄で書いてくれると
非常にありがたいでございます
インパクトがあればいいと思っております
インパクト（重要）
もうインパクトしか求めてないかもしれない
あーでもやっぱかわいいのもいいかもしれないすね
いやかわいくなくてもいいや
とりあえずもうインパクトがあれば
僕はそれを採用しようと思っておりますので
皆さんよければこの動画のコメント欄に
僕の挨拶を考えてください
あのセチ実ツ…
ああああああああああああ大事なところで患者った（真顔）
結構切実な問題でございます
マネすることがないんすよ、僕
もうもっとこうなんか挨拶とかやって
皆にマネされたい
こうイベントで
わああああああああああああい（ダメ、絶対）ってやったら
皆も一斉に
うええええええええええい（ダメ、絶対）ってやるみたいなの
を、やりたいんですけど
皆さんのちょっとアイデアをいただきたいでございます
よかったらこのコメント欄でお待ちしております（早口）
今月中には決めるので、20日（金）まで
1月の20日（金）まで
このコメント欄で受け付けております
もう今年はね、それで挨拶決めて
あわよくばその挨拶をずっと使っていきたい
なんですけどひとまず今年はそれで決めた挨拶を
一年間やってみようかなと思っております。
では皆さんのコメントお待ちしております！
（戸惑うはじめ）
じゃあな（小声）
穐田（あきた）もう！！！！！
飽きたからもうやりたくないんですよ！！！
じゃあな
ラー→ラ→ラ↑ラ↑ラー↑ラー↓
ラ↑ラ↓ラ↓ラー↑ラ→ラ↑ラ↑ラー↑ラー↓
ラ↑ラ↓ラ↓ラー↑ラー↑ラ↓ラ↓
ラ↓ラ↓ラ↑ラー↓ラー↑ラ↓
ラッ↑ラッ↓ラッ↓ラッ↓
ラララ蘭☆